- We have never lived in a time
where brand was this under priced.
Let me explain.
What is the biggest difference between me
and a lot of people that look like me
or me and the companies that I work with
and I get them there?
It is the fact that I
do branding not sales.
Branding is different than sales.
I love when people come up to me like,
"Gary, I'm a marketer."
I'm like, "cool, what do you do?"
"Well I am affiliate
marketer and it's, you know,
"conversion based, top of the--"
I'm like you're a salesman, bro.
[heavy electronic music]
You've got your perspective.
You just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
[music fades out]
Unless you are producing content
that is meaningful to an audience
on this device, across
seven or eight platforms.
Podcasts, LinkedIn, YouTube, Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter, Tumblr.
Like, unless you're producing content
in written form, audio form or video form,
across seven to ten apps, on this device.
Unless you are relevant on those ten apps,
LinkedIn, YouTube, Twitter, Instagram.
If you are not, you are
fundamentally irrelevant in society.
This is a very important
thing to understand,
because I know there's people sitting here
who have an eleven million dollar business
and are super happy and
aren't even on social media.
I get that, but what
you're not factoring in,
is what happens next.
To me what's most important, is not today.
I stand up here and so
unbelievably appreciative
of that reception that I just got,
that knowing how many of you
came here to hear me speak.
But I promise you as I
breath here right now,
I recognize that
literately everything I did
an hour ago and back is irrelevant
if I'm unable to execute going forward.
Tomorrow if I start
making the wrong decisions
and not executing.
Begins the vulnerability of
unwinding everything I have done
and I think we all understand society,
we react much heavier to
mistakes than we do to successes.
The reason I'm pushing
that you're irrelevant
if you're not here is I
don't think everybody here,
including myself has factored in
how much more attention is going here.
Let me promise you this, no matter what
you think about technology
your kids on iPads all day,
you always on the phone,
nobody talking to each other.
How you judge kids 'cause they don't
shake people in the
hand and look in the eye
and all the other horseshit
that demonizes technology.
Right this second, the way
we interact with technology
is the most basic you will
ever see in your life.
Ten years from now, every
one of these phones,
every one of these video games platforms,
every one of these
websites, are going to seem
like a fucking beeper and myspace.
You have to understand this, here's why,
there's nobody here pot
committed enough to this,
including myself.
There is nobody in this theater right now
pot committed to this
enough, including myself.
When I say, pot committed
to this, what do I mean?
I mean every person in this room
needs to take a substantial
step back and understand,
am I producing enough pictures, videos,
written words in these platforms
to achieve what I want?
And the answer, and I'll save
you time, is no for everybody
and for somebody who is putting out
85 pieces of content a day,
across audio video and written word a day,
my answer is staggeringly no.
Meanwhile, there are people here who take
four and half hours to figure
out a perfect Instagram post,
because they want it to look good
when somebody lands on
their fucking profile.
(audience clapping)
It's true.
The quickest gateway,
the quickest execution
for everybody here to
get whatever the hell
they're trying to get out of here today
is to produce content on ten websites.
The quickest way for you
to get what you want,
in your life, is to
produce videos, pictures
and written words, across
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram
LinkedIn, YouTube, Podcast, Your website,
email, text messaging platform, period.
You know what's crazy?
I literally wanna say right now,
"Thank you, London. I'm out."
It is like, I'm thrilled
to go into the mind set
I'm thrilled to tell you, and
if you follow me on Instagram
this is where I've taken
most of my content.
I'm thrilled to tell you that the reason
you are not producing enough content
is unfortunately you value
other peoples opinions
more than you your own
ambition and happiness
that literally pants_47
can leave a content
that you're ugly and it
makes you stop posting
I can go into that, I can go
into a million other things
but I make this very clear and obvious
the reason I am just beginning
to succeed in my ambitions
is because today is the
least amount of content
that I will produce, because
I will produce more tomorrow
and more the next day.
You have to understand,
media dictates everything.
Right, there is a specific
reason that when there's a coup
in a country that the
army goes and takes over
the T.V network and the newspaper,
communication is the game.
Maybe because of being
born in the soviet union,
and raised in the US, I had this paradox
of being fascinated by a closed and open
system of communication.
Maybe, because I am an
extrovert and I talk a lot.
I don't know why, but
something came natural to me
my whole life, which is communication.
What are the things that
make people do things?
Right?
What I am fascinated by, is
the democratization of media.
What I am fascinated by
is that everybody here,
how many people here
have been following me
for more than one year?
Raise your hand.
The fact that ninety percent
of this audience knows
that all I want you to do is run Facebook
and Instagram ads and your still aren't,
makes me want to punch all
of you in your fucking face.
(audience laughing)
I mean, literally all I
have been asking you to do
for the last two years is run
Facebook and Instagram ads.
And you fuck faces still aren't.
(Audience Laughing)
And I say this because I put it on film
because I am going to run
this exact video against you.
In five years, on some
platform, telling you
that you missed the golden
era of Facebook and Instagram
because now it is appropriately priced
and you guys have heard me
if you follow me say this,
I regret that I wasn't able to build
my dads business bigger, because I didn't
spend enough on google.
I didn't spend enough.
I had it figured out, it
was called Google Adwords.
It was working.
Yet I still was doing, newspapers
and direct mail and radio and television.
Because I didn't understand the context
of the moment that I was living in.
I didn't have enough experience to know
that I bought something so good,
so under priced, so scalable,
that I didn't squeeze
the fuck out of it enough
when Google Adwords was "the best".
If you follow me, you've heard me say
that Amazon was the number
one spender on Google Adwords
in those early days
and literally used that
under priced attention,
to be what they are today.
I want you to spend on
Facebook and Instagram,
because there's is a possibility
that never in our lives again
will you be able to get in
front of people, at that cost.
Let me just say it one more time
because I really need
you to understand it.
This, right now and this
is why I yell at myself
for the fifty eighty or a
hundred thousand dollars
of my own money that I spend
on ads on these platforms
that continue to build brand.
The truth is, I should spend
more, and this is not a joke,
if I didn't have such a high
expense to run my lifestyle
because I have a family that's fancy now.
(audience laughs)
Let me make it more basic,
if I was single right now,
I would literally go move
in back with my parents
just so I had more money to run
on Facebook and Instagram ads.
I am going to say it one more time,
(audience laughs)
we have never lived in a time, where brand
was this under priced.
Let me explain, what is
the biggest difference
between me and a lot of
people that look like me,
or me and the companies that I work with
and I get them there, it is the fact
that I do branding, not sales.
Branding is different than sales.
I love when people come
up to me and are like,
"Gary I am a marketer"
I'm like "Cool, What do you do?"
"Well, I am affiliate
marketer and it's you know
conversion based top of the-"
I'm like, "You're a salesman, Bro."
You're not building a brand,
you have seven hundred forty-seven urls
that you do landing page
optimization against
and you convert and that's amazing.
I have- being an affiliate
marketer is amazing
other than the fact
that is should be called
an affiliate salesman.
Brand is why you buy Nike,
brand is why everybody
who is wearing jewelry
and watches, right now,
are wearing what they're wearing
because they bought a brand.
Not somebody cookied them on Instagram
and re-marketed to them and
then they bought that watch
for the most part.
And so, I brand and why I love brand
is because it's in perpetuity.
When you build a brand
you can play on that brand
for a very very very long time.
Why Facebook and Instagram are special
and more special than Google
is, is in Google's hayday
it was not that I was
building brand for why my-
I was building sales,
because when you go on Google
all of our businesses are the same.
Because they're blue
letters on a landing page
that you click.
Brand is when your pictures and videos
look different in a feed.
Look, I think I'm coming
out of the gate in this talk
and I'm gonna macro it up in minute.
But I'm coming out the gate
in this talk very tactical,
about the details.
In all my rah rah and fuck what
people say and self-esteem,
and all the mental shit that
I believe in tremendously,
because that's what gives you the engine.
You know, you are not
going to execute shit
if you are depressed or insecure.
So like, I believe in it but
I am putting it on a shelf UK,
I'm putting it on a
shelf with you right now
because an event that is so
heavily marketed against me
knowing that you've heard a lot of this.
I need one thing.
I need two people to leave here
who have been hearing me
pound them in the fucking face
about running ads on these two platforms
to finally say "Fuck it's
enough, I'm gonna do it"
and and watch this, this
is very very important,
and please don't bullshit,
raise your hands,
how many people here have run
Facebook and Instagram ads
and it has not worked for their business?
Raise your hands.
Raise it high, me too.
Because not every execution works.
Not every execution works,
it doesn't mean its not R-O-I positive.
The R-O-Y of a basketball
for me is zero dollars.
Its a billion for Lebron.
Just 'cause you didn't execute
Facebook or Instagram properly
doesn't mean it doesn't
work, it means you suck.
Attention is like real estate,
when Malibu beach front property
or property and buildings
in shortage twenty years ago
go up for the market and you
buy it at the right price
and then the market changes, you win.
The attention on this
device and the platforms
is going to change very soon.
You, are a very unique group of people
that feel that the pied
piper of this opportunity
is worth spending an afternoon with
or two days or an hour, what have you.
It devastates me that you even
pay attention to me at all,
and don't execute on the biggest gift
that I am trying to give you.
Just 'cause somebody has eight
hundred thousand followers
on Instagram and you pay
them a thousand bucks
and somebody else has forty thousand
and they want a thousand bucks.
I'm surprised at how basic people are
and they think the eight hundred thousand
is the better deal.
I understand it makes sense,
the math is pretty clear,
but a good affiliate marketer can tell you
that the conversion is
gonna really matter.
If you're trying to sell something,
whether its a service or a product,
I couldn't push you harder to get
into the culture of DMing influencers
that you think may represent
your brand properly
or just have big audiences
and start asking them
what they would want,
for them to post about
your BtoB sass product or your new app
or your hoola-hoop or
your fucking cool t-shirt
or whatever it may be.
All I ever think about, I am very basic,
I keep shit super simple
on supply and demand,
I overlay attention and then
culture what's happening in it
and then that becomes me
and I will always do that.
No question, the other territory
that I am completely blown
away by, is influencers.
Super under priced
potentially super over priced
but not allocating a couple hundred bucks
a couple thousand bucks, tens
of thousands bucks of bucks
depending on the size of your business,
and putting it into that
tunnel and that funnel
and tasting it for yourself,
is a huge missed opportunity.
Huge.
Let me talk about another execution,
I am really excited about how
tactical I am getting today.
Pre-roll YouTube.
How many people here
consume videos on YouTube?
Raise your hands.
Cool, pre-roll YouTube.
There's a way for you to
segment and target people
based on what they search on
Google and then pre-roll them
based on what they are doing on YouTube.
Meaning there's a
segmentation that allows you
to target every single person,
that searched open houses
in downtown London.
If you're a real estate agent,
selling in downtown London
and he's searching open
houses in downtown London
but then four hours later, he
goes to watch arsenal videos
on YouTube, your pre-roll
can show up first,
based on the context and
data that that person created
in YouTube search.
It is one of the unbelievably strong brand
and sales executions in the game
and you should literally
go home and Google,
'cause I don't know what
Google's proper terminology is
of this segmentation.
How do I segment based on Google search
as a pre-roll YouTube app?
Verbatim that.
How do I search pre-roll YouTube ads
based on Google search queries?
If you're willing to unbelievably work
and understand how the ads work
and unbelievably work and
understand how the pictures,
videos and written words
work, you will hit pay dirt
mainly on the back of what I did earlier
when said "Hey for
everybody that's got it,
wasn't it so weirdly
easy?" The answers yes.
The attention is just
so grossly under priced.
And it won't be.
And so, I'm passionate as you can tell
and Ill tell you something,
how many people here
actually have been, twenty fourteen
how many people have been following me
for more than seven years?
It shouldn't be a lot,
but I want to see it.
Raise your hands.
so for the twenty or
thirty of you, you know,
I got quiet, in twelve,
thirteen, fourteen, fifteen.
Like I was quiet, there wasn't content.
Wine was done, I wasn't
making business videos,
like once or twice a year,
a keynote from a talk
'cause I was doing a little talking.
I got quiet, because there
was nothing to yell about.
[piano music]